es geht jetzt tatsächlich weiter mit dem
von mir von angekündigten top 16
da geht es um den datenschutz zweite und
dritte lesung entwurf eines gesetzes zur
regelung des datenschutzes und des
schutzes der privatsphäre in der
telekommunikation und bei telemedien
dass wir melde geheimnis will die
bundesregierung künftig nicht mehr nur
für telekommunikationsdienste wie
telefon und sms gelten lassen sondern
auch für einige telemedien wie messenger
internet telefonie und wähler
darum geht es im großen und ganzen und
der erste redner der das hier vorstellen
wird es von der csu hans jörg butt wird
gleich das wort bekommen erste
stellvertretende vorsitzende im
ausschuss die digitale agenda aber
zunächst muss noch ein bisschen mehr
ruhe einkehren ihr im plenarsaal und
claudia roth hat das auch angemahnt
und jetzt geht's los mit dem von mir
schon angesprochenen hansjörg durz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin für die
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren heute ist ein guter tag für den
datenschutz denn ist nun nicht mehr nur
schmückendes beiwerk des
telekommunikationsgesetzes oder des
telemediengesetzes sondern er bekommt
nun ein eigenes stamm gesetz somit
schaffen wir einen übersichtlichen
rechtsrahmen für den datenschutz und
setzten die privacy richtlinie in
deutschland um klare jahre datenschutz
regeln schaffen wir auch für die zeit
nach dem ableben der nutzer denn mit
diesem gesetz stellen wir klar dass das
fernmeldegeheimnis der rechtewahrnehmung
durch erben und andere berechtigte
personen in der rechtsnachfolge des
endnutzers nicht entgegensteht und
schaffen somit rechtsklarheit für das
digitale erbe auch die aufsicht über die
einhaltung der datenschutzvorschriften
wird reformiert vor allem erhält der
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte die
ausschließliche aufsicht im hinblick auf
den schutz der personenbezogenen daten
dieses gesetz trägt aber auch dazu bei
kompromisse zwischen bundesrat und
bundestag umzusetzen
das gilt zum einen für die bestandsdaten
auskunft der kompromiss der im
vermittlungsausschuss zwischen den
parteien gefunden wurde findet sich in
diesem gesetz wort für wort wieder zum
anderen werden wir mit diesem gesetz
änderungen am erst jüngst
verabschiedeten telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz vornehmen damit
setzen die änderungswünsche des
bundesrates um der universaldienst für
bürger wird damit gestärkt denn die
vorgaben für die mindestanforderungen
von internetdiensten werden künftig in
einer rechtsverordnung geregelt der
nicht nur der bundestag sondern auch der
bundesrat zustimmen muss die
mindestbandbreite wird somit im breiten
gesellschaftlichen konsens festzulegen
sein und das ist gut so
zudem wird eine änderung bei der
frequenzvergabe vorgenommen damit kann
die bundesnetzagentur künftig neutral
bewerten welches das beste verfahren für
die vergabe des jeweiligen frequenzblock
es ist eine der hauptsorgen der
opposition dass das neue tkg ohne
regelungen zum datenschutz bleibt kann
hiermit beiseite gewischt werden beide
gesetze werden gleichzeitig am ersten
dezember dieses jahres in kraft treten
damit ist die gesetzliche neuordnung des
telekommunikationssektors rechtzeitig
zum ende dieser legislatur abgeschlossen
wir haben den verbraucherschutz gestärkt
die meisten funklöcher werden in wenigen
jahren der vergangenheit angehören und
wir werden den schutz der nutzerdaten
stärken das liegt übrigens auch an einer
innovativen neuerungen die wir im
parlamentarischen verfahren in das tsg
eingebracht haben wir etablieren eine
rechtsgrundlage für die anerkennung von
systemen mit denen nutzer die
einwilligung in die nutzung ihrer daten
künftig auch zentral managen können wir
folgen damit der klaren empfehlung der
daten ethikkommission und wir setzen
damit eine zentrale forderung des
bundesrates um wir wollen jedoch keine
neuen gatekeeper browser einstellungen
müssen deshalb künftig sicherstellen
dass der nutzer welche umgesetzt wird
und nutzer datenschutz einstellungen
auch über den daten treuhänder zentral
vornehmen können
welche technischen und konzeptionellen
vorgaben dafür gelten wird die
bundesregierung in einer
rechtsverordnung mit zustimmung des
bundestages und des bundesrates
festlegen erklärungsbedürftiges
insbesondere wird das verhältnis von
individueller nutzer einwilligung und
der einstellung von treuhändern
auszutarieren ist bei herstelle diese
klärung zu erfolgen hat muss zeitnah
wiederum geklärt werden zentral muss die
souveräne individuelle einwilligung des
nutzers sein als union waren es wichtig
dass auch unternehmen diese dienste
anbieten können müssen denn notwendige
innovationskraft für den datenschutz der
zukunft kommt auch von unternehmen
damit setzen wir ein zeichen für die
verhandlungen der e privacy verordnung
wir werden uns auch dort dafür einsetzen
dass datenschutz auch durch
unternehmerisches handeln gestärkt wird
und eine vernünftige grundlage für die
daten ökonomie der zukunft wird vielen
dank
[Applaus]
soweit also hansjörg durz der hier die
debatte eröffnet hatte zum gesetzentwurf
der bundesregierung und auch zu anträgen
der fdp-fraktion die hier drei anträge
insgesamt eingereicht hat enrico kölling
spricht als nächstes für die s d
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
kollegen die nutzung von
telekommunikation und telemediendiensten
des längst zu dem tummelplatz
schlechthin von kommunikation von
meinungsaustausch von handel und von
kultur geworden und genau wie
plattformen keinen rechtsfreien raum für
nutzer bieten dürfen müssen überwachungs
auswüchse des staates ebenso wie
datenmissbrauch durch anbieter wirksam
verhindert werden
klassische klassische telekommunikations
formen verlieren an bedeutung mit der
mutwilligen nur vermeintlich kohler
bedingten zerstörung der klassischen
analogen wirtschaft und unserer
gesellschaft verlagern sich viel
schneller als noch vor kurzem befürchtet
die meisten lebensbereiche in die
digitale parallelwelt nicht bitcoin
sondern daten sind die währung des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts das
bedeutet der kunde der endverbraucher
muss wissen welche und wie viele daten
eher für welche leistung preis gibt er
muss herr seiner daten sein und der
staat muss ihn dazu in die lage
versetzen sicherheitsbehörden müssen
gefahrenabwehr und strafverfolgung nach
rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen betreiben
es kann kein freifahrschein für
ausspähen innerhalb von
telekommunikations und
telemediendiensten geben den gläsernen
bürger meine damen und herren lehnen wir
ab
und auch unternehmen und auch
unternehmen die für erbrachte leistungen
daten der endverbraucher erheben und
nutzen wollen müssen grundsätzlich immer
auf die einwilligung des daten gebers
angewiesen sein
wir begrüßen daher im grundsatz die
bündelung der datenschutzbestimmungen in
einem
gesetz das bislang bestehende
nebeneinander von datenschutz grund
verordnungen telemediengesetz und
telekommunikationsgesetz hat auf allen
ebenen bei verbrauchern bei den
diensteanbietern und aufsichtsbehörden
zu vielerlei rechtsgrund sicherheiten
geführt die regelungen im einzelnen
bleiben aber zu häufig im ansatz stecken
und sind nicht oft zu ende gedacht
die behördliche verantwortung für die
durchsetzung einzelner regelungen bleibt
in dem neuen gesetz offen der
bußgeldkatalog des paragrafen 26
tt der sg entfaltet nach wie vor kaum
abschreckungswirkung der ganze blödsinn
der weder transparenz schafft noch den
verbraucher in seinem recht auf
informationelle selbstbestimmung wirksam
schützt wird durch dieses gesetz leider
auch nicht behoben
die einführung eines pdms eines personal
information management service zb zum
umgang mit cookie anfragen und zur
einwilligungs verwaltung wird auch in
diesem gesetz nicht umgesetzt
damit wird die chance eine verbraucher
und eine anbieter freundliche
ausgestaltung leider vertan dass bei
einem solchen wichtigen gesetz zudem
ohne aussprache im ausschuss zu einer
beschlussempfehlung kommen musste und
dass in diesem bereich nicht
federführend der innenausschuss befasst
war bleibt aus unserer sicht ebenfalls
kritikwürdig deshalb meine damen und
herren lehnen wir dieses gesetz ab
vielen dank
vielen dank enrico kölling und der
nächste redner in dieser debatte kommt
aus der spd-fraktion falko mohrs sitzt
im ausschuss digitale
agenda und spricht jetzt hier zu dem
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung ja
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren datenschutz hat in den
letzten jahren sehr deutlich und
zunehmend an bedeutung für uns alle
gewonnen natürlich mit zunehmender
digitalisierung mit den zunehmenden
digitalen verhalten in kommunikations
und arbeitsbereich als beispiele hat
eben die bedeutung der selbstbestimmung
darüber welche daten über mich wo und
wie gespeichert genutzt werden natürlich
zugenommen und wir schaffen hier mit dem
tt dsg also dem telekommunikations
telemedien datenschutzgesetz ein neues
stamm gesetz in dem die
datenschutzbestimmungen zusammengefasst
werden das heißt wir verhindern eben
dass wir bisher in unterschiedlichen
gesetzen widersprüchliche teils
widersprüchliche regelungen gestanden
wir schließen mit diesem gesetz einige
lücken die beispielsweise noch oft waren
die umsetzung der richtlinie und
schaffen so ein konsistentes stammen
gesetz für den datenschutz im bereich
der kommunikation das meine damen und
herren ist gut und es schafft
rechtssicherheit für alle
das gesetz beinhaltet auch klar stellung
im bereich des digitalen erbes stellt
nämlich klar dass das fernmeldegeheimnis
nicht den rechten des abnehmers
entgegensteht insofern es auch hier ein
jahrelange rechtsunsicherheit mit diesem
gesetz die beendet wird weil im kleid es
schaffen wird das auch das digitale erbe
an die erben weiter geht sofern nichts
anderes geregelt ist auch hier wichtig
dass wahrheit geschaffen wurden
therme und wir alle kennen das ist
angesprochen worden dass wir wenn wir im
internet unterwegs sind permanent
konfrontiert werden mit bannern die
wollen dass du bei cookies zustimmen
oder auswählen welche art der cookies
wir denn eigentlich wollen und am ende
führt das dazu dass die meisten von uns
eher genervt den schnellsten weg suchen
wie ich diese banner eigentlich los
werde und endlich auf die website kommen
und nicht dazu führt dass wir uns
bewusst entscheiden ob wir einwilligen
in welcher art der cookies wir
einwilligen und was das eigentlich zur
folge hat und deswegen ist es wichtig
meine damen und herren dass wir auch
hier mit diesem gesetz eine grundlage
für personal information management
systems also teams schaffen wo wir
nämlich sagen in zukunft wenn diese
teams eingesetzt werden sollen wo ich
ihm bewusst sagen kann bei bestimmten
anwendung stimme ich zu
bei anderen stimmig nicht zu dass hier
in bestimmte grundlagen und eckdaten
beispielsweise unabhängigkeit gewahrt
werden bis man es eben nicht sein darf
dass der anbieter eines solchen systems
dem ich am ende an vertrauen mit meiner
einwilligung verantwortungsvoll
umzugehen dass dein eigenes interesse
hat das muss aber weil es eben sehr
kompliziertes durch rechtsverordnung
noch aus definiert werden das muss durch
den bundestag durch den bundesrat und
dann haben wir hier eine gute grundlage
geschaffen die damen und herren und
lassen sie mich die letzten sekunden
noch mal ganz kurz etwas persönliches
nutzen denn wir wissen ja alle nicht was
in den nächsten monaten auch kommt aber
höchstwahrscheinlich wird es im laufe
dieser debatte die letzte rede von
meinem wirklich sehr geschätzten
kollegen gustav ertl nach 23 jahren im
bundestag sein und über gustav ich sagte
nach der wirklich intensiven
zusammenarbeit nicht nur bei dem sondern
vor allem im bereich des
telekommunikationsgesetzes ohne zu
übertreiben es war mir eine freude war
mir eine ehre mit ihm zu arbeiten von
denen lernen zu dürfen und war ist nicht
nur gezeigt dass du verantwortung
übernehmen kannst sondern dass du sie
auch über geben kannst wirklich von
herzen herzlichen dank für deine arbeit
und eine unterstützung
[Applaus]
falko mohrs
ich danke ihnen letzter redner für die
fdp-fraktion manuel höferlin man in
berlin ist der digital politische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben kolleginnen kollegen ein bisschen
ist der gesetzentwurf und vereinen der
änderungsantrag ein bisschen
vergleichbar mit der operation
abendsonne wohl noch personal auf den
letzten drücker untergebracht werden
soll sollte man manchmal auch ein
bisschen den eindruck dass sie noch
schnell ein paar dinge einfügen wollen
die sie vielleicht in der nächsten
legislatur nicht mehr so gestalten
können
ich möchte ich möchte auf einen punkt
eingehen den sie per änderungsantrag
vorgestern abend noch eingefügt haben
auch wieder mit viel vorlauf für die
opposition
sie kapern regelrecht den begriff dieser
pimps dieser personal information
management systems es ist eine
nebelkerze
denn das was sie da in dem
änderungsantrag machen ist überhaupt
nicht im c't sondern es ist im prinzip
ein deal endes cookie einwilligungs tool
im prinzip ist es eine helferlein das
päckchen setzt automatisiert es ist aber
nicht ein wirkliches system um die
informations selbstbestimmung der
menschen zu organisieren und zu managen
was wirklich nutze weiterbringen würde
wenn sie wie geschaffen würden um
intelligente assistent zu schaffen die
nutzungsbedingungen analysieren die
datenschutz präferenzen vornehmen und
wir wissen alle dass cookies heute in
der nutzer nach verfolgung gar nicht
mehr das mittel erster wahl ist dass das
mittel von den 80ern und nicht mehr na
ja vielleicht ihre und 80ern zu lang so
saskia esken würde das so sagen sie hat
ja auch das digitale system so
bezeichnet aber die kugel es gibt schon
sehr langen heute werden ganz andere
mitte wo genau die neunziger sehr gut
auch sonst im gesetzentwurf packen sie
eigentlich eine alte checkliste ab denn
die cookie richtlinie gibt es seit über
zehn jahren und sie setzen sie jetzt
endlich um meinen und herren der
koalition das ist
für das ist pflicht was ihr heute
abliefern wir haben einen gesetzentwurf
ihnen heute vorgelegt und ich weiß liebe
kollegen der koalition sie lesen die
punkte nicht immer so dass der
zusatzpunkt fünf vielleicht nehmen sie
sich ihn nach der debatte noch mal zu
herzen
wir schlagen ihnen vor einen kern
datenschutz thema noch einmal
aufzugreifen und zwar geht es um zur
stärkung und die stärkung der
datenschutzaufsicht auch in diesem
gesetz was sie vorlägen gibt es wieder
keine befugnisse für den
datenschutzbeauftragten gegenüber
öffentlichen stellen das ist aber
dringend notwendig deswegen es ist auch
nicht erklärbar warum jeder vereinen vor
ort mit der mitgliederverwaltung ein
verfahrensverzeichnis anlegen muss und
dort dann auch geprüft und auch
sanktioniert wird von den
datenschutzbeauftragten aber weiterhin
öffentliche stellen davon ausgenommen
sind und sie machen das auch in ihren
jetzigen gesetz wieder das ist nicht
nachvollziehbar und das muss sich
dringend ändern
deswegen wollen wir mit unserem
gesetzentwurf den wir ihn vorlägen dass
der bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte das was
die so genannte jungtier richtlinie
vorsieht auch machen kann nämlich dass
er bei der polizei in der justiz
beispielsweise ein christ befugnisse hat
dass er handeln kann das was er jetzt
machen kann nämlich eine verwarnung
aussprechen das hat ungefähr die
wertigkeit eines klassen 51 meine damen
und herren nicht mehr
sie können das gerne aufnehmen das
bundespolizei gesetz das seit wochen
geschoben wird übrigens von ihnen das
soll ja nächste woche auf der
tagesordnung stehen
ich fordere sie auf fügen sie dass dort
noch ein schaffen sie den datenschutz
ein entsprechendes gewicht und in
richtung innenministerium sage ich nehme
sie das gitter an sich im
wirtschaftsministerium ist der
datenschutz leider nicht so gut
aufgehoben und warten sie bitte nicht
wieder zehn jahre bis dahin
herzlichen dank marielle hall verliehen
war das hat hier von einer pflicht statt
von einer kür gesprochen denn
tatsächlich sind in diesem gesetz wird
jetzt gesagt dass das speichern oder
auslesen von cookies oder ähnlichen
informationen nur erlaubt ist wenn der
nutzer die nutzerinnen dem zugestimmt
hat das ist aber längst in der e privacy
richtlinie der eu von 2009 schon so
geregelt und wird erst jetzt in
deutsches gesetz aufgenommen anke
domscheit berg spricht jetzt für die
linksfraktion
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe kollegin
bei der ersten debatte zum
telekommunikations und telemedien
datenschutzgesetz habe ich es als
telemedien überwachungsgesetze
bezeichnet denn jetzt ein erneuter
versuch die b und die bestandsdaten
auskunft gesetzlich zu verankern nachdem
das bundesverfassungsgericht bereits
zwei solcher versuche verfassungswidrig
fand die linksfraktion mit diesem gesetz
daher nicht zustimmen
heute möchte ich meinen fokus legen auf
die ausbeutung personenbezogener daten
zu werbezwecken die der gesetzentwurf
ebenfalls neu regelt dann darum geht es
bei den harmlos klingendem die
zulassungen europäisches recht verlangt
eine gesetzliche pflicht zur
einwilligung für jeden einzelfall von
kuki datensammelei auf basis klarer
informationen aber was heißt denn das in
der praxis da gibt es überall ein
missbräuchliches design dieser
einwilligungs popups jeder von uns kennt
das der alles akzeptieren button groß in
der mitte fett rot bunt vorausgewählt
der alles ablehnen button meistens gibt
es ihn gar nicht der einzeln auswählen
button ist super unsichtbar und gut
versteckt findet man jedoch landet man
in einem labyrinth von unterseiten soll
unzählige einzel entscheidungen treffen
und das ist ungefähr so abschreckend
die 70 seiten kleingedrucktes ag.de so
werden einwilligungen erschlichen und er
trickst und nutzer innen genötigt dass
ein bewegungs prinzip fördert aber auch
soziale ungleichheit denn sehr oft
begegnen uns im netz zwei optionen wer
all dies zulässt darf angebote kostenlos
nutzen der privatsphäre
der soll dafür zahlen aber wer will dann
eine gesellschaft in der privatsphäre
ein privileg für wohlhabende ist die
linksfraktion will das
jedenfalls nicht wir müssen also endlich
klären welche art von profilbildungen
dürfen überhaupt zulässig sein
die frage ist relevant denn ihre folgen
sind weitreichend die ausbeutung
personenbezogener daten zu werbezwecken
ist das zentrale geschäftsmodell im
internet und weil personalisierte
werbung dieser art auch das
geschäftsmodell von facebook und co ist
führt das am ende zur verbreitung
polarisierender inhalte wie lauffeuer
und vergiftet unsere gesellschaft gegen
diese fehlentwicklung hilft nur ein
verbot der massenhaften durchleuchtung
von internetnutzer innen für werbezwecke
denn auch mit einer einwilligung darf
nicht alles erlaubt sein siehe organ
handeln die linksfraktion fordert daher
die bundesregierung auf sich für
ethische grenzen bei der profilbildung
bei dem trilog verhandlungen in der eu
zur e privacy verordnung einzusetzen
im übrigen bin ich der meinung
informationen zu
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen haben nicht
zum strafrecht verloren § 209 10 a
gehört abgeschafft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nächster redner in der debatte ist
konstantin von notz er ist der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der grünen fraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag wechselte für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen dr konstantin von
notz
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen die digitalen bürgerrechte sind
das herzstück des liberalen rechtsstaats
im digitalen zeitalter und so viel lässt
sich sagen nach dieser legislatur und
den letzten wochen
sie sind bei der großen koalition in
schlechten händen diese digitalen
bürgerrechte meine damen und herren
während die große koalition kurz vor
toreschluss noch jeder
sicherheitsbehörde offenkundig
verfassungswidrige befugnisse wie die
online durchsuchung in die hand geben
und die massiven rechtlichen probleme
bei der quellen-tkü beim handel mit
sicherheitslücken oder bei zieht es ganz
bewusst nicht angehen ist erstens weit
über 1000 tage nach der von der eu
gesetzten umsetzungsfrist der j ii
richtlinie noch immer nicht vollständig
umgesetzt und zweitens die dringend
erforderliche e privacy verordnung
während ihrer eu ratspräsidentschaft
nicht einen millimeter voran gekommen
meine damen und herren so geht es nicht
diese jahre lage nicht regulierung des
digitalen wandels ist schlecht für den
grundrechtsschutz der menschen in diesem
land und er ist auch schlecht für die
rechtssicherheit von unternehmen das
direkte ergebnis von alldem kennen wie
aale anke domscheit bergs angesprochen
ist eine nervtötende flut von kubanern
die wir jeden tag alle sich mal erleben
und um ganz am ende der wahlperiode als
große koalition noch mal richtig unter
beweis zu stellen wie chaotisch man in
diesem bereich agiert lassen sie das tt
dsg nicht etwa eben für den datenschutz
federführende innenausschuss verhandeln
sondern im wirtschaftsausschuss erst
nach der sachverständigenanhörung führen
sie dann in einem änderungsantrag etwas
völlig neues ein
nämlich dass einwilligungs management
das einwilligungs management und das
sozusagen erst in der zweiten kurve ja
diesen wesentlichen bausteinen das zeigt
dass das von tankred schipanski oft
beschworene feuerwerk digitaler
gesetzgebung der großen koalition
in wahrheit ein tischfeuerwerk voller
rohrkrepierer und nebelkerzen ist
tankred schipanski
ja so ist es es ist grundsätzlich
richtig und wichtig dass die
datenschutzregeln in ein eigenes gesetz
kommen und das bei den cookies endlich
lösungen geschaffen werden
die datenschutzrechtliche einwilligung
darf nicht ad absurdum geführt geführt
werden sie braucht eine gute rechtliche
absicherung gleichzeitig muss es aber
gänzlich untragbare bereiche geben dass
liefern sie leider nicht das gesetz
beinhaltet weiter auch
verfassungsrechtlich zumindest
problematische daten auskünfte all dass
der datenschutz schützt die daten er
schützt die informationelle
selbstbestimmung und die menschenwürde
der bürgerinnen und bürger und er ist
eben kein nice to have
das muss die grundlage unserer politik
sein die gruppe hat das leider in dieser
wahlperiode nicht geliefert das ist sehr
bedauerlich hoffentlich wird es ab
september besser vielen dank
die tochter von seinen fans guckt auf
die bundestagswahl beziehungsweise auf
die zeit danach und ich sage es nochmal
falls es doch menschen gibt die sich
fragen was hier die cookies ende über
die gesprochen wird das sind dateien die
die website auf computern der nutzer
speichern und dann so zum beispiel dann
wissen wenn ein nutzer zum zweiten mal
auf einer seite kommt ob er da eben
schon mal drauf war oder er kann auch
die aktivitäten der nutzer für
werbezwecke nachverfolgen axel knoerig
spricht jetzt für die unionsfraktion
mitarbeiter in den ressorts wirtschaft
innen und justiz an die arbeitsgruppen
der koalitionsfraktionen und
insbesondere an hansjörg durz und falko
mohrs die mühe der letzten wochen hat
sich gelohnt das gesetz zur regelung des
datenschutzes und des schutzes der
privatsphäre in der telekommunikation
und bei telemedien kurz tsg was wir
heute verabschieden ist ein wichtiger
schritt und ich ergänzen ist auch ein
notwendiger schritt lassen nämlich aus
sicht der cdu csu
die drei wichtigsten elemente nennen und
auch entsprechend einordnen ich beginne
hier vom ende her
endlich wird der digitale nachlass
geregelt zum digitalen nachlass mit
einer zahlreichen klagen von erden und
klargestellt dass die rechtewahrnehmung
durch erben dem fernmeldegeheimnis nicht
mehr entgegensteht
damit können erben einen zugang zu den
daten des verstorbenen erhalten um die
nachlassverwaltung auch ihr zu
organisieren dieser schritt meine ich
war längst überfällig
und wir haben weiterhin waren
datenschutz im internet sinnvolle
verbesserungen erzielt bundesregierung
koalition haben sich darauf verständigt
dass das permanente bestätigen oder
anpassen von werbe anfragen der
vergangenheit angehören
das anpassen von tracking waren war nie
ein beitrag zu mehr datenschutz
jetzt gilt feste vor einstellung zur
werbung auf dem smartphone sind
rechtswidrig surfen im internet wird
obgleich ob es mobil oder stationär
erfolgt wird mit dem neuen gesetz
leichter bequemer und vor allem sicherer
es ist über 20 jahre her da hat sich die
deutsche telekom aufgemacht mit dem
projekt der virtuellen kommune kommunale
verwaltungsdienstleistungen in
deutschland zu digitalisieren nicht erst
weiter corona panini wissen wir dass
diese vorhaben überwiegend nicht
erfolgreich waren die digitalisierung
der öffentliche
verwaltung des bis heute viel zu oft
noch kein vorzeige projekt wir spüren
doch bereits an manchen stellen den
verlust staatlicher kompetenzen abläufe
zu langsam und zu kompliziert sind nicht
alles aber vieles hängt dabei und einer
unzureichenden digitalen infrastrukturen
einem mangel an vernetzten denkens das
heute zu verabschieden gesetz für
besseren datenschutz ist zweifellos
wichtig es bliebe aber stückwerk wenn es
nicht eingebettet wird in eine neue
daten kultur und diese neue daten kultur
die besteht aus vielen elementen wenn
wir die digitalisierung der verwaltung
rasch also innerhalb der nächsten
legislaturperiode vollziehen wollen ist
ein element hier entscheidend für den
erfolg der open data ansatz open data
bedeutet es gibt einen wirtschaftlich
und auch gesellschaftlichen mehrwert
staatliche daten zu veröffentlichen
wir gehen hier mit der bundesverwaltung
beispielhaft voran definierte standards
und zudem die grundlage für
geschäftsmodelle bei denen
unterschiedliche ideen und ansätze im
wettbewerb gegenüber stehen und dennoch
kompatibel bleiben
dieser wettbewerb hilft auf vielen
startups und vor allem mittelständischen
unternehmen sich erfolgreich mit dem
großen tech unternehmen zu messen denn
alle haben den gleichen programm ihr
struktur den gleichen quellcode als
zugang zum schluss ein wort zum
datenschutz der zukunft
ich glaube dass die datenschutz grund
verordnung der eu eine richtige
entscheidung war
und dennoch muss sich die weitaus
größere zahl an nutzern auf der welt an
die gsv nicht gebunden fühlen
was tun die finnische initiative my data
versteht nutzer von smartphones im
internet als respektierte daten gebe
die idee ist simpel aber effektiv die
menschen sollen auch beim teilen ihrer
daten im besitz ihrer daten bleiben und
jederzeit auch die kontrolle darüber war
das schaffen wir nur mit staatlichen
datenschutzvorgaben
die dsg durch zwei instrumente mit
personal informations management system
wird das einwilligungs management daten
treuhänderisch organisiert und browser
werden der werkseinstellung verpflichtet
das nicht zu behindern
das ist der moderne geistes tt dsg im
zentrum eines modernen datenschutzes
sollte also immer der schutz erhobener
daten vor fremden zugriff stehen und das
ist gewährleistet
ich bin ganz sicher wir stehen vor dem
beginn einer neuen daten kultur mit dem
ttsg liegen wir heute immer in die
datenschutzrechtlichen grundlagen dafür
dass sie informierte einwilligung zum
zugriff auf persönliche daten durch die
bürgerinnen und bürger gestärkt wird
das ist ein erster schritt und darüber
freue
vielen dank
axel knoerig und damit kommen wir zum
letzten redner hier in dieser debatte es
wurde ja schon angekündigt danach wird
über den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung sowie über zwei anträge
der fdp abgestimmt über einen dritten
antrag der fdp wird nur entschieden das
ja an die l an die ausschüsse überwiesen
wird
23 jahre einsatz für unsere
parlamentarische demokratie
wir bedanken uns dafür und ich wünsche
ihnen von ganzem herzen für den nächsten
abschnitt alles gute viel neues viel
aufregendes und bleiben sie gesund und
jetzt haben sie das wort zu ihrer
letzten reagiert
vielen dank
das auch met ist entschieden liebe
kolleginnen kollegen aber zunächst zur
sache wie ich es 23 jahre gehandhabt
habe mit artikel 13 in diesem gesetz
reformieren wir nochmal ein stückchen am
telekommunikationsgesetz wir gehen
insbesondere auf wünsche der länder ein
die länder können mitbestimmen bei der
verordnung für den universaldienst wir
öffnen etwas mehr die möglichkeiten der
bundesnetzagentur bei der nächsten
frequenzversteigerung das ist gut so
deswegen bitte ich sie dem gesetz
zuzustimmen und über falco
ich kann den dank zurück geben für mich
war es wirklich jetzt in dieser letzten
wahlperiode schön mit dir noch einmal
richtig gas zu geben in dem ganzen
bereich der telekommunikation ich finde
wir haben uns toll ergänzt du musst mir
nur eins verzeihen wenn ich irgendwann
über das wort glasfaser
bereitstellungsentgelt stolperer dann
werde ich immer an dich denken
liebe kolleginnen kollegen im herbst 20
18 habe ich die menschen in meinem
wahlkreis und meine partei informiert
dass ich nicht erneut für den deutschen
bundestag kandidieren werde
sechs mal direkt gewählt denke das
reicht
ich werde im oktober wenn der deutsche
bundestag erneut zusammentritt 63 jahre
alt sein kann auf 46 jahre arbeitsleben
zurückblicken davon 23 jahre im
deutschen bundestag auch dass es etwas
was genug ist für ein kleines
menschenkind ich bin heute muss ich
gestehen ähnlich aufgeregt wie bei
meiner ersten rede die ich noch in bonn
halten dürfte
nur es sind es heute andere gefühle
nämlich das gefühl erstens der wehmut
auch selbstbewusstsein und dankbarkeit
und als ich vor 46 jahren politisch
angefangen habe im gemeinderat zillertal
hat niemand gedacht dass der gast ein
junger und erhaschen kerweborsch jemals
23 jahre erfolgreicher arbeit im
deutschen bundestag leistet so kann es
passieren
ich sage das selbstbewusst weil ich als
chemielaborant immer versucht habe die
probleme sauber zu analysieren und klare
lösungen zu suchen
und ich habe eine bitte an die parteien
alle die es zum teil ihre aufstellung
schon vorgenommen haben es gibt
vielleicht etwas bedarf an
handwerklichen und naturwissen verstand
im deutschen bundestag
ich bedanke mich ganz viel bei den
mitarbeiterinnen des bundestages in den
ministerien landesvertretungen verbände
unternehmens selbstständig in den
journalisten die hintergrundgespräche
mit der rheinpfalz werden mir fehlen ich
bedanke mich bei den mitbewerbern ich
habe mich immer gerne mit ihm gestritten
und noch mehr gefreut wenn wir zu
kompromissen oder sogar zur
einvernehmlichen lösung gekommen sind
wie in den schönsten gremium des
bundestages chemisch anhören dürfte dem
parlamentarischen weinwoche ich sage
danke an die spd fraktion andrea nahles
rolf mützenich sehr in bad hall und
kirsten lima die haben mir vertraut die
haben mich einfach machen lassen und ich
bin stolz darauf der besten landesgruppe
dieses parlamentes angehören der
spd-landesgruppe rainer schüttler vielen
dank dass du den staffelstab übernommen
hast
danke an meine mitarbeiterinnen ohne ich
das nie geschafft hätte im wahlkreis
johanna hoffmann die seit 1998 seit
beginn mich da betreut hat trägt sie
jakob christiane rücker und jonathan
greil aus die immer für die notwendige
boden haft
geachtet haben wenn ich aus berlin
zurück geflogen bin hier in berlin
ariane mainzer hat mich durch das
raumschiff navigiert rachid el khatib
durch die themen agrar verkehr und
digitales wissenschaftlich begleitet gut
fortgesetzt von anna rosenberg und maxi
hopst die jüngste neueste in meinem team
erinnert ich dann immer wieder einmal
einiges unbestimmtheit in der user zeit
lieber kolleginnen kollegen ich komme zu
den wichtigsten teil aller meiner rede
im deutschen bundestag
ich bedanke mich bei meiner familie weil
sie hatte die eigentliche last zu tragen
wenn ich als abgeordneter unterwegs war
und ich sage ihnen ich bin ein
ausgesprochener glückspilz warum weil
meine frau und meine kinder larissa und
dominik mich noch immer lieben und was
kann es schöneres geben wenn man hier
auf den deutschen bundestag ausscheidet
vielen dank
alles gute es war mir eine ehre
ja und da wirkt es jetzt applaus ja es
im deutschen bundestag
fraktionsübergreifend sechs mal direkt
gewählt viele ich denke dass erreicht
sagt gustav herzog alles gute und
genießen sie hoffentlich einen guten
jahrgang also weil meine ich gut damit
schließt sich die aussprache
tagesordnungspunkt 16a wir kommen zur
abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur regelung des
datenschutzes und des schutzes der
privatsphäre in der telekommunikation
und bei telemedien der ausschuss für
wirtschaft und energie empfiehlt in
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache 29 839 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf drucksachen 27 441
und 28 396 in der ausschuss fassung
anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die den
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
dankeschön sehr stimmt dagegen
dankeschön wer enthält sich der
gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
beratung angenommen zugestimmt haben die
fraktionen von spd und cdu csu dagegen
gestimmt haben die fraktionen der linken
der fdp und der afg und enthalten hat
sich die fraktion von bündnis 90/die
grünen dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich jetzt so erheben
dankeschön
wir stimmten dagegen
wer enthält sich dankeschön
der gesetzentwurf ist angenommen
zugestimmt haben die fraktionen von spd
und cdu csu dagegen gestimmt haben die
fraktionen von afg fdp und der linken
und enthalten hat sich die fraktion von
bündnis 90 die grünen bekommen zur
abstimmung über den entschließungsantrag
der fraktionen der afc auf drucksachen
29 855 wer stimmt für diesen
entschließungsantrag dankeschön
wer stimmt dagegen dankeschön bei zwei
enthaltungen
bei zustimmung der fdp fraktion und
gegenstimmen von allen anderen
fraktionen des hauses der
entschließungsantrag abgelehnt
tagesordnungspunkt 16.10
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
inneres und heimat zum antrag der
fraktion der fdp mit dem titel
verwaltung und behörden zu starken
dienstleistern machen strategie für den
einsatz künstlicher intelligenz vorlegen
der ausschuss empfiehlt unter buchstabe
a seiner beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache 29 818 den antrag der
fraktion der fdp auf drucksache 22 182
abzulehnen
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
dankeschön wer stimmt dagegen wer
enthält sich dankeschön die
beschlussempfehlung ist angenommen
zugestimmt zu haben hier immer werden
die beschlussempfehlungen angenommen
wurde dass daneben
in der beschlussempfehlung stand dass
der antrag der fdp abgelehnt wurde
die fdp fraktion hat noch einen zweiten
antrag hier eingereicht über den
abgestimmt wird mit dem titel
germany souveränität den nutzerinnen und
nutzer über ihre it systeme
gewährleisten
auch darüber stimmen jetzt die
abgeordneten ab und das können wir auch
sehen ihr nachdem wie sie ihre hand
heben